this week on my drunk kitchen we're all
up in your grill people like to say my
shows a little corny I'm like you don't
like it go call the cops for you my
colonel
cool I'm good I got a quiche coming so
you know a big day big day
what is it too much is that a red eye
red eyes er that's that's that's a cup
of coffee and a shot of espresso within
that do you want to like vibrate out of
this you just say I'm gonna change
timelines buddy I can't even drink
coffee yeah I had to switch as soon as
like my life started to take real like
shape in a direction I really enjoyed I
started reacting really strongly to
caffeine so he had to switch to tea yeah
I would have coffee I was just drinking
so much coffee and it was just like it
was I couldn't sleep at night and I was
like why do I feel like I'm in a
constant state of terror yeah yeah here
you guys who's texting me I'm busy this
is a kid oh my god the kid don't look
your part you're all awful nobody look
this is a private moment
just pour beer inside I can't do it just
put never mind just put the chicken on
the grill and fake it give it the
dignity of a pup
okay huh poor bird ma'am yeah so
thank you I'm actually wearing one of my
tribute pieces I wore this hat and see
my drunk kitchen Super Bowl special Oh
ready for some kitchen yeah
- mom football sports huh I was so
excited I can't believe that game I
cannot believe it anyway thank you I
appreciate your condolences huge Beyonce
fan I didn't think that Beyonce is I
don't think Beyonce's in the Illuminati
for one reason specifically is that
Beyonce is super independent you know
she runs her own [ __ ] Beyonce's I'm
gonna be in the Illuminati she don't
need the Illuminati she can start a new
Illuminati that will consist entirely of
just her now I just really respect her I
mean not only is she obviously gorgeous
she is deeply talented but also kind of
uses herself as her own tool which I
understand through a very very very
small extent for being like I'm running
my own business
I am also the product that my business
produces you know it's a weird great
disconnect no I am about six or seven
months into becoming a youtuber I quit
my job and started couch surfing and
then I dedicated myself full-time to
creating a YouTube channel and I just
was living on my friends couches and
traveling around and going different
places and taking any co.labs or any
opportunities I could take and trying to
hustle you know make it happen make it
all come true and that's I'd like to
bring you O hard o the tour
the show at the show and adore
incredibly excited to take this show on
the road
the advice I would offer if I could go
back first of all I don't believe in
regret you know so I don't regret
anything I definitely would have made a
couple of decisions differently but at
the same time I'm so happy with how
things have turned out that even the
suffering it took to get here was
probably worth it to a fair extent you
know this is a story of my 50 shades of
chicken hand a water bottle there is my
job a there is some food and stuff this
is a store all good my office oh good
this is the story of my life it's my
house this is my floor this is my house
well hopefully the kitchens not [ __ ]
up oh no the kitchens roofin but for
those people who want to do this sort of
field I would say 100% make things that
you want to make that are true to your
voice and no matter how authentic that
is or like no matter how vulnerable that
is to be that authentic because if
you're trying to be somebody else and
that fails then you have nothing if
you're being yourself and that fails at
least you have you know a lot of respect
for within you know show me where your
noms - radio dogs - show me where your
knob set
show me where your dongs at Radio Times
that baby got a problem